مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا عبيده
[موسيقى]
نفع شوف موضوع توزيع المنتخبات بدور ال 16
بكاس اسيا عامل عامل حاله من يعني الخربطه
والجدل والناس عم تتوقع وتحلل وتسوي وما
حدا فهمان شيء من نظام البطوله ومين رح
يلعب مع مين
والمتصدر رح يلعب مع الثالث ولا مع الثاني
والثاني بيلعب مع المتصدر ولا مع الثالث
والدنيا فايت ببعضه وكل الناس عم تسال
منتخب بلدها مع مين راح يلعب كل الناس
متحمسه لتعرف لحد الان عرفنا مباراتين
بدور 16 رسميا مباراه سوريا وايران
ومباراه الامارات وطاجاكستان نحن عم نحكي
لحد يوم الاربعاء الساعه تقريبا اربعه او
خمسه بتوقيت الدوحه اللي بعد مباراه
العراق و فيتنام ما خلصت صارت باخر دقائق
واليابان مع اندونيسيا ايضا صارت باخر
دقائق ولكن ما عرفنا النتيجه النهائيه حتى
الان تشير النتيجه لتقدم العراق 3 اثين
يعني العراق متصدر للمجموعه الرابعه رسميا
بتسع نقاط كامله حتى هذه اللحظه عسى انه
ما يصير في اي تغيير حتى نهايه المباراه
نحن اليوم جايين نعطي
ال النظام تبع البطوله السيستم تبع
البطوله كيف وزع الفرق المتاهله الى دور
ال 16 على حسب الفرضيات وعلى حسب المراكز
المتوقعه لكل منتخب لانه مثل ما بنعرف بعد
في مجموعتين رح يلعبوا يوم الخميس هن
مجموعه ا هن المجموعه الخامسه اللي هي
مجموعه الاردن البحرين كوريا وماليزيا
وبالاضافه للمجموعه الاخيره اللي هي
مجموعه السعوديه وعمان وقرغيزستان
وتايلاند لذلك رح نعطي الفرضيات مع اي
اشراك طبعا منتخبات بكره ولحد الان مش
عارفين مين راح يحتل المركز الثالث او مين
الاربع ثوالث اللي تاهلوا 100% عرفنا منهم
سوريا وعرفنا فلسطين وبعد باقي نعرف
منتخبين اللي راح يتاهل كثوث عن المجموعات
السته خلينا نبدا بالمنتخب القطري المنتخب
القطري رح يواجه ثالث او رح يواجه ثالث
اما المجموعه الثالثه او الرابعه او
الخامسه يعني رح يواجه اما المنتخب
الفلسطيني اللي هو اجا بالمجموعه اجا ثالث
المجموعه الثالثه او المنتخب
الاندونيسي بحال طبعا اندونيسيا رجعت قدرت
تحصد المركز الثالث وتاهل مجموعه العراق
او راح يواجه واحد من البحرين او الاردن
او كوريا الجنوبيه اللي فيهم راح يحتل
المركز الثالث رح يلعب مع المنتخب القطري
بشكل مباشر اذا خيارات قطر واضحه قطر
عندها اما المنتخب الفلسطيني او ثالث
مجموعه العراق واليابان بحال تاهل او ثالث
مجموعه الاردن وكوريا الجنوبيه والبحرين
بنروح على المنتخب اللي بعده اللي هو
المنتخب السوري المنتخب السوري طبعا رح
يلعب ضد ايران حسب الموضوع و 100% سوريا
ضد ايران ب 31 الشهر المنتخب الاماراتي رح
يواجه طاجاكستان 100% هذا امر تاكد مليون
بال بنروح على المنتخب الفلسطيني المنتخب
الفلسطيني عنده خيارين يا رح يواجه اول
المجموعه الاولى او اول المجموعه الثانيه
يعني يا رح يلعب مع قطر يا رح يلعب مع
استراليا هذول الخيرين المتاحين امام
المنتخب الفلسطيني بالنسبه لحسب المنتخب
العراقي المنتخب العراقي خلينا نفترض انه
تصدر مجموعته بعد الفوز على فيتنام وانتهت
المباراه بفوز او تعادل المنتخب العراقي
العراق متصدر للمجموعه الرابعه والعراق رح
يلعب مع ثالث المجموعه الخامسه او السادسه
يعني رح يلعب اما مع منتخب اي كوريا او
البحرين او الاردن من المجموعه الخامسه او
رح يلعب مع تايلاند او عمان من المجموعه
السادسه واضحه العراق ضد ثالث المجموعه
الخامسه او السادسه طيب بنروح على الاردن
الاردن والبحرين حسبتهم وحده عمليا لانه
اذا واحد منهم احتل المركز الاول او احتل
المركز الثاني الفرضيات وحده بالنسبه لهم
وممكن اي منتخب منهم يحتل الاول او الثاني
او الثالث لذلك اذا احتل المنتخب الاردني
او البحريني المركز الاول ضد مين بيلعب
اذا احتل المركز الاول رح يلعب المنتخب
الاردني او المنتخب البحريني مع اليابان
اليابان هي ثاني المجموعه الرابعه
وبالتالي اذا الاردن تصدرت مجموعتها رح
تلعب مع اليابان واذا البحرين تصدرت
مجموعتها رح تلعب مع اليابان واذا كوريا
تصدرت مجموعتها رح تلعب مع اليابان
وبالتالي اعتقد انه كل فرق هي المجموعه
وخصوصا البحرين والاردن ما بيتمنوا انهم
يتصدر المجموعه لانه اليابان مثل ما بنعرف
هو اصعب منتخب رغم فوز العراق عليه ورغم
انه الم الموضوع بين انه بتقدر تفوز عليه
وبتقدر تنتصر والامور طبيعيه بحال الاردن
او البحرين اجوا بالمركز الثاني رح
يواجهوا متصدر مجموعه السعوديه يعني راح
يواجهوا السعوديه او تايلاند هذا امر بكره
رح يتحدد رح نشوف مين رح يكون متصدر
مجموعه السعوديه او تايلاند ولكن الثاني
من مجموعه الاردن والبحرين وكوريا راح
يلعب ضد متصدر مجموعه السعوديه يعني ممكن
نشوف الاردن السعوديه ممكن نشوف البحرين
السعوديه ممكن نشوف كوريا السعوديه بالدور
الثاني اما صاحب المركز الثالث بهي
المجموعه فمثل ما حكينا سابقا رح يروح
ليواجه المنتخب القطري يعني اذا الاردن
طلع الثالث لعب ضد قطر اذا البحرين طلع
الثالث لعبت ضد قطر اذا كوريا طلعت الثالث
لعبت ضد قطر بالدور بدور ال 16 او بالدور
الثاني بالانتقال للمجموعه الاخيره اللي
هي مجموعه السعوديه السعوديه مثل ما حكينا
الخيارات واضحه بالنسبه لها بحال صدرت رح
تلعب مباشره مع البحرين او الاردن او
كوريا ثاني المجموعه الخامسه اما اذا
المنتخب السعودي جاء في المركز الثاني
بمجموعته وخسر المباراه القادمه امام
تايلاند وتايلاند تصدرت فهو المنتخب
السعودي بروح بيواجه اوزباكستان بشكل
مباشر لانه اوزبكستان هي ثاني المجموعه
الثانيه وبالتالي السعوديه خيارات واضحه
اما الاردن او البحرين او كوريا او
اوزبكستان بالدور الثاني اما عمان عمان عم
بتنافس على مركزين اما الثاني بحال خساره
تايلاند بنتيجه كبيره من السعوديه وفوز
عمان على قرغيزستان بنتيجه كبيره هون
بصراحه مش متاكد اذا ممكن ياخذ المواجهات
المباشره ولا فرق الاهداف ولكن خلي نفترض
انه امل عمان ممكن بالمركز الثاني ولو اني
مش متاكد من المعلومه ارجو انكم تصحوني
اما او انه يتاهل كمركز او كصاحب مركز
ثالث المنتخب العماني بحال تاهل كصاحب
مركز ثالث عن مجموعه السعوديه راح يروح
مباشره ليواجه منتخب العراق اذا عمان بحال
تاهلت كثالث المجموعه السادسه رح تواجه
متصدر المجموعه الرابعه اللي هو المنتخب
العراقي طبعا لائحه البطوله وتوزيع
المنتخبات هو امر صعب ومعقد وفي كثير من
من الحسابات ومن القصص اللي راح تحدد
الامور ها ولكن نحن جربنا نستعرض الفرضيات
اولا وجربنا نحاول نتكهن او نتوقع مين راح
يلعب ضد مين بالدور الجاي وهاي الخيارات
القائمه حسب لائحه البطوله وحسب ما
المنظمين وزعوا الفرق المتاهله بنهايه
الامر بالتوفيق للمنتخبات العربيه جميعا
المتاهله واللي ان شاء الله تكون على وشك
التاهل وان شاء الله انه بنشوف بطوله
ممتعه جدا ومباريات ناريه بدور 16 من كاس
اسيا هذا كان كل شيء بحلقه اليوم من بعد
الصافره حتى نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل كونوا
بالف
خير
ه